what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another installment of our
beyond omega level series where we go
over the origins and powers of the
strongest characters in comics and
today's video was suggested by a viewer
with the username i should be studying
which is amazing and this might be the
first character we've covered that has
actually been canon canonically i always
have a hard time pronouncing this work
that has actually been officially
designated as explicitly being beyond
omega level in marvel comics something
that a lot of you guys may not know
oftentimes when it comes to a character
being considered beyond or beyond omega
level they're not often inferred or
directly stated as being that level of
power it's more the things they've done
with the power they have that puts them
in that category but while this
character has the potential to be the
greatest threat the marvel universe has
ever seen he has an incredibly boring
name alpha
so apple was created by dan slot in
humberto ramos and first appeared in
amazing spider-man number 692 in 2012.
now in this issue we're introduced to a
student at midtown high named andy
mcguire named after the two actors who
had played spider-man at that point in
time andrew garfield and tony maguire
now andy is largely ignored by his
parents and is basically your average
student he's not especially smart or
athletic or even popular but one day he
forges his father's signature on a
permission slip and goes on a field trip
to horizon labs where peter parker shows
off his new discovery which he's humbly
named parker particles
now parker particles as peter explains
are a form of energy tied to the
expansion of the universe and are
capable of producing near limitless
power so you can probably figure out
where this is going but during the
demonstration one of these scientists
disengages the safeties on the equipment
causing the energy created by the
particles to break containment and as
you have probably predicted andy mcguire
finds himself doused in energy now not
only does he survive much to the
surprise of everybody watching but he
immediately manifests superhuman
abilities as he creates a force field to
shield his classmates from falling
debris now naturally andy's parents hire
attorneys and they threaten horizon labs
with a lawsuit for nearly killing their
son but the lab brings in the world's
foremost experts in studying superhumans
reed richards tony stark hank pym and
hank mccoy also known as beast all of
whom are basically there to try to find
a solution now in the examination of
andy maguire they find that every cell
in his body has been permeated by the
parker particles and that they
constantly charge and recharge to
provide him a variety of superhuman
abilities in their assessment they
determined that andy's list of powers
include energy projection super strength
super speed and flight pretty much
run-of-the-mill stuff for any superhero
furthermore they discovered that andy is
only able to use one of these powers at
a time so for instance he cannot fly and
use energy projection at the same time
he can only do one or the other but
here's where things get interesting
because undoubtedly asking yourself how
in the world does the ability to fly and
punch hard make this guy beyond omega
level patience rob core patience so
here's where things get interesting as
reed richards tells peter that over time
andy's powers will continue to grow this
is because they are tied to the universe
itself and the universe is constantly
expanding reed even says that while the
hulk the century and the phoenix force
are designated as omega level threats
that andy goes beyond that and will
eventually become the first ever alpha
level threat which doesn't really make
sense from a naming perspective because
alpha comes before omega in the greek
alphabet and also when clarifying
mutants alpha level mutants are already
a thing and they're not as powerful as
omega level mutants but whatever the
point is that andy mcguire is stated to
be beyond an omega level threat so we
don't even have to debate whether or not
he belongs on this list because we know
he does marvel told us he does
and the fact that he will one day
surpass the phoenix force really lets us
know that he's one of the biggest
threats the marvel universe has ever
seen now because he's so powerful and
because peter parker is partially to
blame for him existing it's decided that
spider-man will be responsible for
training andy furthermore to avoid a
lawsuit horizon labs agrees to a
lucrative contract for andy to be a
spokesman for them which leads to him
becoming a superhero and adopting the
name alpha now peter parker who is
believed to be an associate of
spider-man among other things makes his
suits and stuff like that is basically
put in charge of making a suit for alpha
but he foolishly does not include a mask
meaning that the whole world knows
alpha's real identity this means that
back at school andy mcguire is now the
big man on campus and of course all the
fame and popularity goes to his head and
turns him into just a ridiculous dick
now when the fantastic four and
spider-man encounter a monster named
giganto their combined efforts proved to
be insufficient to defeat him despite
being told of course to stay out of the
conflict alpha comes to their aid and
defeats giganto with one punch
officially making him one punch man but
as the press gathers around alpha
declares that he is on his way to
joining the avengers and that spider-man
has been designated his sidekick and so
all the heroes have basically figured
out that at this point alpha's gonna be
a problem now alpha continues to become
an increasingly horrible human being and
he his family his lawyer and a girl that
he was cheating on his girlfriend with
are all kidnapped by the jacqueline who
clones alpha but the clones don't have
alpha's power since his dna was not
actually altered now after being rescued
alpha kills his clones and decides he's
had enough of being mentored and moves
to new york to increase his celebrity
status this of course leads to peter
parker to decide that something has to
be done about this guy so as peter
searches for a way to rid alpha of his
powers the earth is attacked by a
villain named terminus but this guy
draws the attention of the avengers
including thor captain marvel vision
iron man and captain america and even
with all that power they're unable to
defeat terminus naturally of course they
turn to the biggest weapon they have
which happens to be alpha who shows up
and starts pelting terminus with energy
blasts now even though this is effective
in defeating terminus the energy that's
deflected in battle knocks several
planes out of the sky including one with
aunt may on board because you know
what's a spider-man story if aunt may's
life not in jeopardy of course
spider-man saves aunt may and then also
takes some of the tech that terminus
used to deflect alpha's attacks and
figures out a way to drain alpha of his
energy which basically depowers him and
forces him to go back to his old life as
a nobody at midtown high now later after
otto octavius switches bodies with peter
parker he decides to give alpha 10 of
his power back under the pretense of
giving alpha a second chance to prove
himself worthy of being a superhero but
in reality it was an attempt to
basically harness the power for himself
which you would expect because dr
octopus is nothing if not a dick so the
story that follows this is pretty
unremarkable if i'm being honest but the
one thing we do learn from it is that
alpha has a power not previously
mentioned which is matter manipulation
and if you've followed our beyond omega
level series you'll probably recognize
that this is a very common power for
beyond omega level characters as it
basically allows them to do whatever
they want the trouble with this and
really with alpha as a whole is that we
don't ever really see him put his powers
on display other than beating up aliens
who are too much for the fantastic four
or the avengers which isn't really that
much of a surprise we really don't get
to see alpha do much we're just told
that he has the potential to become an
alpha level threat but hey at the rates
sony's optioning movies based on obscure
spider-man characters maybe we'll see an
alpha movie and see more of his powers
on display i have no idea you debate in
the comments whether or not it's a good
idea that sony's doing this
but let me know what you guys think but
do you guys think that we should see
more of this character in comics or do
you think he's one of those examples of
a character who's just better left out
of the picture right like it's cool
he'll become really powerful one day and
that's all we need with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
let me know what you guys think as
always make sure you leave a comment
down below for characters you want to
see and i will catch you all later
peace